pour la rentrée 2010 8,7 un tout nouveau
réseau de bus qui accueillera le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
restructurer un réseau parfois caduque
telle était la volonté de
l'agglomération nous avons commencé dès
le mois de février je crois 2016 à
travailler avec l'ensemble des douze
maires pour voir comment on pouvait
remettre à plat le réseau de bus voir ce
qui était pertinent voire les lignes qui
étaient vraiment beaucoup emprunté celle
qu'il était moi etc voilà de tout
remettre sur la table via des
questionnaires les attend de trois mille
usagers ont permis l'amélioration du
réseau certains tracés ont été créés
comme la ligne 8 qui reliera la gare de
villepreux les clés à celle de plaisir
gueugnon le réseau sera également
renforcée en soirée et le week-end + 10
% de course lors de ces périodes
nous n'avions pas beaucoup de bus le
week-end pas de le soir donc maintenant
nous allons avoir des bus 7 jours sur 7
jusqu'à minuit sur certaines lignes ce
qui n'existait pas y compris des bustes
dimanche les itinéraires des bus se
rééquilibre pour permettre aux villes
telles que magny les hameaux de
bénéficier plus facilement du réseau de
saint quentin
autre ambition augmenter les fréquences
et réduire le temps d'attenté aux heures
de pointe
à l'arrivée hier des lignes express
alors les lignes express c'est une
sondés l'hymne qui seront en vente en
heure de pointe tous les quarts d'heure
et sinon à la demi heure ça n'existait
pas sur nos sur nos lignes actuelles ou
parfois mais il fallait même attendre
parfois plus d'une heure pour voir plus
pour pour avoir un bus qui fait que
finalement au bout d'un certain temps
d'attentes les gens prennent leur
voiture en tout 2000 sans cours
supplémentaires par an seront réalisés à
partir du 3 septembre prochain afin de
faciliter encore plus le déplacement de
la population